aujourd'hui on va faire chanter lâche un
phrasé et des mots adaptés un public
bien particulier dans la salle le plus
jeune à trois mois ce spectacle entre
dans le cadre du festival baby âge
un rendez vous dédié à la petite enfance
on trouve très peu de spectacle sur la
petite enfance
certains parents imaginent que les
enfants d'un livre ils ne savent pas
parler les livres n'est pas important
pour eux alors qu'on se rend compte à
chaque fois que ça éveille de tas de
choses des comptines qui capte
l'attention des petits poissons de la
médiathèque de la verrière
c'est un spectacle qui vraiment
fonctionne avec des tout petits au
départ les les gens n'y croient pas trop
quand il les emmène mais ça fonctionne
vraiment c'est la pollution
un spectacle pour parler environnement
mais aussi la toute-puissance la
fontaine aux grenouilles finit par ne
plus obéir aux deux comédiens des
détails qui ne va pas au bon temps et je
suis de chez le chouchou de judo
on était très très agréablement surpris
en fait puisqu'on n'était pas trop sûr
de la réaction des enfants et ils ont
été scindés temps il est pris dans la
magie du spectacle et
et ces gens ils ont apprécié un éveil à
l'imaginaire pour cet instant des
tout-petits organisé par le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis sept ans